Like a boss. For some reason, I
think if I'm fluent in Spanish,
I can go down to South America
with that South America.
Why did that just pop in my head?
Remember that fucking song that
David Bowie and a Mick Jagger did
dancing in the streets and
they will rubbing their ass
is together and they were
yelling all the fucking places,
different countries out.
And then Mick Jagger goes South America
[inaudible]
and it made me like the stones
a little bit less. Um, anyways,
I figured if I can go down there
to South America, I would fucking,
uh, if I could speak the language, I
could talk my way out of being kidnapped.
You know,
you have to watch that show
arrested abroad abroad.
You ever seen that shit?
Fucking people go now I'm,
I think you don't have to take,
I'm going to do is martial artists guy.
I think I've been a fucking ride a
motorcycle from here to the tip of South
America.
I decided to ride a motorcycle to
the tip of South America and back.
You know, and guess what happens? It
gets like a third of the way there.
He goes,
left on fucking Venezuelans that are
right on fucking a Chalupa right?
It's just this premonition that
something's gonna go wrong.
And that's when I started going,
hmm,
do I turn it around or do I keep going?
Next thing you know, he's, he's
there a bunch of fucking gorillas.
They're just looking at like,
is this like entrapment?
There's no way it's this easy.
Did a fucking white guy on a Goddamn
vesper just turned down this dirt road in
the middle of the fucking rainforest?
Is the,
is there a fucking death squad
behind this guy? You know,
and I just figure if you actually spoke
the language instead of these people
walking around, I'd get it.
Right. Cause that's what,
that's what Spanish sounds like to a white
man like me or I'm going to elaborate
that map map until you
fucking break it down.
I just think that that would be good
to be laying in the tent. Keon dog.
You know what? We're not going to
fucking kill this guy right now.
We're going to kill him tomorrow instead
of it sounding like I'm now all right.
And then maybe you could figure out how
to get out of there. So that's what I do.
So like, you know what I've always
wanted to do? I want to go out,
I want to go to the, uh,
the Galapagos Islands.
I think he would have to go through
Columbia or Venezuela, you know,
those places down there, you know,
instead of having like, they have like a
Pablo Francisco Boulevard,
I mean,
I'm not going to that street as a
Goddamn redheaded white man. Hey,
how are ya? Who'd like to a kidnap
me first and all me for ransom,
you know,
when they say you've got to watch out
who you fucking hang out with that,
that's one of those times you really
have to watch out who you hang out with
because if you hang out with a bunch of
fucking losers and you get kidnapped and
they start demanding money for you,
that's going to be a rough one.
Jim
[inaudible]
Oh, Steve. Yeah.